it's an experiment and in hearing
confident like pushing the reset button
of your soul that make sense it's
glitter bombs that will live inside
every one of your orifices sure we'd
wait
all right from the creators of Bonnaroo
and outside lands and the network that
made it cool to say come to comedy and
music mashup of festival proportion
Comedy Central Presents colossal
collector fence featuring Jerry Seinfeld
Kevin Hart bill burr Sarah Silverman
Chris Hardwick and a special appearance
by your actual soul mate we fun time
musical performances by IQ Tegan and
Sara
chromeo Preservation Hall Jazz Band been
stable and more glitter bomb plus Bob
Odenkirk pignataro fred armisen little
Dicky Moshe kasher to those Queen Chris
Keller ginger Minj Bob the drag queen
Michelle buteau James Adomian
hey Larson Joe DeRosa Nate bargatze
Charles mutters oh did we mention Jerry
Seinfeld I don't what I am this one but
wait there's more Hannibal Burres will
be there it's so broad city Reggie Watts
and Maya Rudolph's print cover man
princess plus Roy Wood jr. Rachel blue
lot of Ferris how did this get made
podcast it's super jam featuring Les
Claypool's master jazz explore the
worlds of your favorite comedy it's like
South Park honey
Seinfeld good luck with all and It's
Always Sunny in Philadelphia Central
Presents colossal cluster fest June 2nd
3rd and 4th in San Francisco
I will be there can we go now can we
just be there we just be there now just
see you a cluster fast